des annonces qui ont été reçus comme une
douche froide pour le monde culturel la
réouverture prévue le 15 décembre pour
les cinémas musées ou château a été
repoussée de trois semaines du côté de
luynes la famille georges et avait bon
espoir de relancer son cirque de noël
une vingtaine d'artistes devait se
produire sous le chapiteau et la
billetterie était prête
tout a été annulé on retrouve aurélie
renault et nico la laverie le en
compagnie d'hervé georges et nous sommes
sur la piste du cirque georget qui
restera vide
cette année hervé georges et quelle a
été votre réaction
hier suite aux annonces du premier
ministre mais plein de 2 2 la n 2 de la
colère de deux on est on est vraiment
pris pour pour des quelque chose qui
n'est vraiment pas essentiel alors
peut-être que c'est vrai pour certains
mais je pense que qui gère qu'est ce qui
dit qui décide ce qui est essentiel à la
vie de tout le monde
voilà d'habitude chaque année il y à un
spectacle qui fait venir des milliers de
personnes ici aline environ 30000
personnes je crois pendant tout le mois
de décembre et tout était prêt et le
public était au rendez-vous le peu de
communication que nous avions fait via
les réseaux sociaux
nous avons eu une effervescence
incroyable danser avec le public était
là c'est encore une perte alors là il ya
la casquette économique qui parle mais
c'est une perte record énorme
et puis et puis de l'autre côté voilà
tout était prêt la billetterie avait
plus qu'à appuyer sur ok on était
reparti la communication les artistes
les artistes aujourd'hui papa
aujourd'hui c'était hier soir hier soir
ça a été une catastrophe de tous les
côtés du plus petit au plus grand
puisque même mon fils qui a qui a 8 ans
m'a envoyé un texto je n'étais pas chez
moi m'a envoyé un texto en me disant
papa y aura pas de spectacle cet hiver
c'est une première pour nous c'est une
première pour tout plein de gens on
restera chez nous et voilà j'en suis
très triste
avant tout pour notre clientèle puisque
c'est pour nous aussi un ascenseur
émotionnel c'est oui c'est non c'est
rouge et blanc et et on avait dit au
public on serait là et c'est pas notre
faute on ne pourra pas être là alors on
parle d'une activité qui pourrait
reprendre début janvier
que ferez vous à partir du 7 janvier
quand on vous autorisera éventuellement
à reprendre
les activités la magie de noël sera
perdue nous c'est vraiment un concept
qui est fait avec le cirque et noël
alors le 7 janvier bien sûr on va
pouvoir rouvrir l'école de cirque
peut-être j'espère déjà mais au niveau
des spectacles pas tout de suite pas
tout de suite puisque pour nous on vient
de perdre une année mais dans
l'événement en événementiel on est en
train de perdre une deuxième puisque ça
se met en place des mois et des mois al
avance tout ce qui est une manifestation
un spectacle et on est vraiment vraiment
mal parti parce que là on est parti pour
une deuxième année york
merci à hervé georges et donc on
rappelle que la piste du cirque reste
ravi de cette année ici à luynes